you
hi everyone is cheering let's have a
look at a game from the 2018 Biel chess
festival this is a round one game that
was played today between Magnus Carlsen
playing on the white end rated 2842 and
David Navarro rated 27:41 so let's dive
right in and see how this one develops
opening Queens gambit declined variation
Rogozin one of the more topical lines at
the top level I've included the clocks
for each player just to the right so you
can get a rough estimate of the amount
of time spent on each turn time controls
are 100 minutes apiece you gain 30
seconds when you make a move and there's
some bonus time it move 40 and 60 50
minutes and 15 minutes respectively both
time controls are met in this game so
how quick and bounce is now present
night for Bishop exchange this is the
one piece that sticks out to me now
unopposed dark square Bishop rooks see
one and move a not yet committing the
bishop white would prefer to recapture
on c4 in one swing if allowed black
allows it black captures on c4 now and
then plays c5 I question the timing of
these moves I wondered why black is
let's say being so polite allowing this
recapture in one turn why not play c5
first I believe an issue with playing c5
first is that white can saddle black
width and isolated deep on and I believe
that this is seen more so as a liability
than an asset in this environment and so
it is first captures on c4 only then c5
d takes C Knight d7 and a small decision
point for white
you can castle or you could also
consider breaking up the a B structure
with c6 this Pawnee is going to fall so
c6 is an option to damage the queenside
structure white places an emphasis on
development castles it is Knight takes
e5 and after Knight b5 this is where
things now sharpen I'm once more drawn
to the bishop in this case because it is
staring off into space there is no white
piece for it to capture and if black
does not act fast
black is going to lose some material the
threat here is a three and after the
bishop backs up B form forking the
bishop and Knight black understands this
and black on move and now starts giving
direction to white in fact these next
three moves throw punches at the white
miners a3
excuse me a6 b5 and now II 5 this is an
important moment in the game a big
decision for team white you don't
necessarily have to react to this threat
Carlsen does react to this threat but
there is something else to consider and
I imagine this move is what was
considered on this move 15 I'd like to
draw some attention to this moment in
the game it's a big one a3 is likely a
move that was considered by Carlsen but
maybe not played for the following
reason this position that Springs about
becomes a bit on the simplified side
just working with major pieces same
colored bishops black may very well be
able to pick up this pawn right now
could be some technical issues on the
back rank but this is becoming ensure a
bit on the simplified side and it may be
difficult to try and press for the full
point
the decision at this moment is on this
move 15 to sacrifice the Queen the move
played Knight c2 is the Queen sacrifice
after rook d8 there is no better move
than to capture on b4 this is the idea
that white had in mind at this moment
right here
Knight c2 is the queen sac rook d8
Knight takes Bishop rook takes Queen in
here we are
the number one thing white has to have
in this imbalanced position is
coordination white has just that white
also has a tiny bit more on the
development side all pieces are
functioning rooks are ideally placed
occupying the to only opened files from
here a five-night d5 black has to defend
the knight from here Knight takes e5
taking advantage of the fact that the
Queen is overloaded had two jobs
so now material imbalance what are we
looking at night rook and pawn versus
Queen getting some more development in
Bishop b7 Bishop f3 a lot of
repositioning in this one trying to find
good squares for pieces for both sides
rook c8 now that the knight is defended
this is on this is a threat Queen takes
Knight Knight g4 counterpunch addresses
this threat and now Knight f6 is a
threat this Knight to f6
whit's check picking up the Queen Queen
FA
h4 multi-purpose some square some air
for the King and one day maybe this pawn
can kind of cramp the King side pawns h5
so some reposition the rooks are
exchanged cannot recapture with the
Queen 97 game over so the bishop
recaptures a3 this is now the only base
point white needs to be careful about if
there's pressure on it there's some
defense rook on d2 these pieces will
find good squares the white pieces will
be able to find good squares h v g6
defending h5 Bishop e2 this pawn is
under fire black ignores it
playing 95 and then this pawn is picked
up next this is one thing I wondered I
wondered why maybe this isn't you know
why doesn't black try to hang on to this
pawn it could be difficult to do that
you know devoting the Queen to its
defense I mean for one there's the move
b4 Ike has to be very careful I mean
there are some possibilities to pick up
the bishop
you know if black tries to go on the
offensive there is 97 and then Knight
takes Bishop and maybe in the end this
pawn still falls it's kind of tricky to
hang on to the beep on or if b4 there
can be a capture and then rook d4
hitting it twice it's tricky to defend
black gives it up and instead places an
emphasis on repositioning the night it's
a strong piece probably Black's best
piece now the knight on e5 Bishop takes
b5 Bishop b7 Knight c3 and now here
comes the black queen white better be
coordinated find good squares for pieces
because this Queen could be you know you
could really strike at two unprotected
pieces and at the moment there's only
there's only a couple B 2 and H form
that's defended first rook D for the
queen is now starting to slip in put
pressure on the weak point B to Knight
f1 Queen b3 rook d2 and night C for
another important moment what do you do
here is white the decision is to not
take the knight if you take the knight
this is it's tough to kind of press in
this position you kind of see a little
back and forth like this I don't know
that you could really move forward let's
say as white in this position if you
capture on c4 so instead we have rook d7
this is like this this is the second
instance where white is really trying to
show you know I'm I'm not looking to
have this position feeder down to a draw
I want to inject some imbalance I want
to keep some imbalance present
we get exactly that what's rook d7
Knight takes b2 rook takes Bishop Queen
takes Knight and now the King position
is brought into question white targets
f7 another interesting interesting
moment this time an option for black to
capture the pawn on a or not in the game
King f8 is played if the Queen captures
this pawn it's true this guy becomes
passed but it may it may be the case
that all of these pawns fall to the
bishop something like this and yeah you
could see these guys be picked up and
white I'll have four connected passed
pawns it's a tough call I really don't
know how to assess that end game yes
there would be all these passed pawns
but you know how fast can they really
move they go too far then the King is
maybe a bit vulnerable really tough to
assess the decision by navara at this
stage is to play King f8 and now get a
couple p6 changes in Queen c6 is
basically forcing the continuation rook
takes Knight King takes bishop this is
what happens in the game doing something
else trying to let's say keep the rook
trained on the bishop would be losing
for white because black can really start
to coordinate the knight and queen on
the weak squares and White's camp f2 can
quickly become a great sensitive point
in White's camp just taking out a few
moves to show there's even something
like Knight to e1 the Queen and Knight
are killers
threat on g2 and if f3 there's double
attacks Queen b6 hitting everything okay
not a good idea to play rook to a7 in
this case it's rook takes Knight King
takes bishop and where do we stand
two pawns a night in a rook versus a
queen coordination still number one for
white must stay coordinated let's see
how white tries to manage this rook d2
Queen a4 I didn't throw a pop quiz your
way pop quiz after Queen a for both
pawns are hit one will fall which one is
more important to hang on to feel free
to pause the video okay if you said the
a pawn well done can't lose that guy the
a5 bond becomes passed that's too strong
that would be too strong for team black
so white allows this pawn to be captured
the H pawn know that this guy is not
passed now whiting starts to check I
think this is one of those you know you
just kind of get a quick move in maybe
make black think a little bit we know in
the end where this rook really wants to
be first throw a question to the King
King g8 rook d4 this is where the white
rook wants to be on a secure Square
defended by the pawn and now after the
move a 3 white maintains coordination
rook defends a 4 everything is glued
together there's no you know there's no
way to really break down the white side
now if you look at the computer
evaluation it's reading at the moment
okay - point 1 1 you can't look at that
and say black has an advantage this is a
position type where it is only white
that is playing for two results there's
no great progress for black to be made
the rook cannot be challenged when it's
on d4 it patrols
fourth-ranked and that means that the
king could never cross into whites house
and why could always just play moves
like g3 king g2 or make knight moves
there's no way to break down the white
side so how to make progress is the big
question how can white try to make
progress let's see how this takes shape
getting a few more moves in this is an
interesting decision playing g5 and then
g4 it's true that the Jeep on would
clamp down on this structure but they
become a bit of a liability as they move
forward not sure maybe maybe a better
idea is to just keep the Queen you know
just keep making Queen moves keep the
king back keep the structure a bit back
but it moves forward in this game g5 g4
meanwhile the night is repositioning and
yeah this pond is now gonna be picked up
black doesn't try to defend it I believe
maybe one of the ideas is that black was
envisioning that without the H pond
maybe there is some possibility for a
perpetual without the H pond around
maybe the Queen can subject a subject
the White King to some checks if it's on
the H file can't be sure that that's the
exact train of thought but okay this H
pond is picked up in the end from here
king g1 some checks it's no perpetual
Knight f4 Knight G to some
reorganization the white rook wants to
be at this moment on the f4 square this
is an important moment could see many
players be tempted by the following move
rook d5 this would not be a good choice
to try and pick up the pawn what would
be the issue with that the issue is that
white is now not coordinated yes you
just won upon but look at F - look at
the rook both are unprotected and guess
where the Queen's gonna go d2 and
something is going to be picked up you
can't win this as white if you're greedy
like this you have to stay coordinated
always so if I just take it out a couple
more moves like this what are you doing
what would white do to defend f2 could
only defend with King g1 and there's
always this perpetual IDR repetition of
position idea you can't do this you
should not do this as white rook f4 is
fantastic really glues everything
together everything is protected and
it's just about finding a good spot for
the night next let's see what white does
Knight h4 Knight f5 and here we go with
efore I'm not quite sure what white
would do if the Queen stayed trained on
the a4 pawn be a bit trickier the knight
could try to let's say get to the e4
square distract the King away maybe even
the f6 Square to pick up the g4 pawn I
could try to converge on g4 in this game
we have Queen d3 the one of the moments
the queen is not observing a4 allows now
this e for advance this is a passed pawn
after all and it gets rolling and there
are some tricks involved the knight and
the rook are nearby the King and there's
a passer
so from here Queen d7 ee5 the rook is
there just in time to defend a 4 Queen
h7 check King g1 and after Queen g6 what
to do here it's very tempting this is
something I tested out in the game I
wondered you know I thought one of the
ideas was to play to e3 playing to e3
converging on this square would not be a
good idea because you really get to see
that the Queen's strength in this
position if Knight e3 is played here
black can make use of h7 b7
and be one delivering checks along the
rank the file the diagonal getting up
the King from all angles so you could
start like this King G - Queen b7 King H
- Queen h7 there isn't an H pawn around
these checks are there and if you're -
if white is to avoid these perpetual
checks it would have to be with
something like Knight f1 but then after
Queen e1 this pawn will fall so no
Knight e3 in this position Knight d6 one
of the ideas is to have this check in
mind and also observe that b7 square one
of the squares the Queen would like to
make use of for these perpetual checks
so there's no perpetual at this point in
the game Queen b6 is played and there's
just one more variation to really
highlight before we see the remaining
moves Queen B 1 if Queen B 1 is played
King H 2 Queen h7 I came across an
interesting line here
after Queen d7 it may be very tempting
to go for the following variation
playing as white rook f5 King g6 rook f6
if the King steps up the rook steps up
and the queen is lost white will go on
to win the King and pawn endgame if the
King goes here there's this mating idea
what's Knight f7 King h5 rook h6 for
checkmate right if Knight f7 in this
position the Queen has to take out the
knight otherwise that's game over watch
how easily Y can slip up in this
position how would black one more pop
quiz how would black defend in this
position after Knight to f7 how would
black defend against rook h6 may feel
free to pause the video okay black could
defend by way of Queen D 5 and then
Queen H
giving up the Queen because in the end
this would be stalemate
anyhow we didn't go down that path just
an interesting variation night found and
what did we have we had Queenie six and
from here the Queen's gonna be lost
after rook have five check if the King
backs up rook f6 in the Queen has to
give herself up for just a rook so black
at least takes out two pieces now the
rook and the knight are captured but in
the end white is up to extra pawns and
is winning this King and pawn endgame
with that four takes King f2 King takes
pawn King f3 and white after King to e3
is winning black resigns at this point
if it did carry out black is going to be
one move shy of being able to shoulder
off the white King and we know what
happens from here white gets a queen and
delivers mate but this is as far as it
went
move sixty-four King to III and navara
resigns if you're interested in the tale
the tape on this one will even if you're
not here it is could have a look at the
inaccuracies mistakes and blunders for
each side two inaccuracies one mistake
zero blunders for Carlsen 15 average
sent upon loss five inaccuracies one
mistake one blunder 31 average sent upon
loss for Annavaram pretty even game
throughout and well at a certain point
there's this little slip-up these
decisions to give up the H pon I'm not
so sure about that
and the the Queen Queen d3 move I
believe is where it really you know that
endgame giving up well allowing the e4
e5 idea
once that pass her got within just a few
steps of promoting there are just too
many threats for team black to parry
anyhow as you
feel free to leave any feedback to this
game in the comment section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
you